I mean it's my name is Corinne petition
I'm the political editor in chief of
Aftonbladet and with me I have Z nib
defect she who is a writer academic
techno sociologist one of the coolest
titles I can imagine she's also one of
the great minds thinking about the
Internet I've been following her and
reading her for a while and she was one
of the first and early voices really
warning about what the consequences
could be of this new information
infrastructure that we are living with
and I guess let's just jump right into
this what was it that you saw when you
started talking about possible possible
negative effects of social media on
truths and the public discourse and what
is happening now so let me start by
saying that from the first moment it was
clear to me that it was both I even
wrote a piece saying is the internet
good or bad yes because it's the kind of
technology that allows people to find
one another in ways that would have been
mediated by gatekeepers before you know
in the past you had to be published in
the New York Times you had to be on TV
before you got attention if you are
living a repressive country it had to be
the authoritarians or whoever's in power
in that country had to permit you and
with these technologies it meant that
people could find one another in ways
that just weren't possible before but
from day one I thought you know we tend
to think of the ways in which this is
great because it lets Egyptian
dissidents find one another it lets
Turkish dissidents find one another
it lets us challenge the mainstream
gatekeepers of what they're keeping out
but it also lets the white supremacist
and Nazis find one another like it
doesn't just work for one group so there
ways in which we have built institutions
since the Enlightenment right we have
built a scientific enterprise we have
built academic Enterprise post-world War
two we have built for better or worse a
kind of journalism was its own ethos it
wasn't perfect it was never perfect but
there were ways in which it controlled
what was in the public sphere in Europe
you have all these hate speech laws for
example for a good reason you have this
history and all of a sudden you had a
way in which people could bypass all of
that that meant everything that was
underlying that was still an issue that
we were controlling by keeping a lid on
it
it was just going to come on this so
what were we keeping a lid on we were
keeping a lid on a lot of things maybe
in some ways like you know sort Aryan
countries that's not good they're
keeping a lid on dissent they're keeping
a lid on politics but in some places we
were also keeping a lid on racism and
white supremacy we were keeping a lid on
say people who believed vaccination is
just you know apply to keep their so it
was all gonna come Unleashed it's almost
like I mean the way so I kept thinking
this is gonna change everything and in
August of 2015 when Donald Trump
announced he was running the whole
existing establishment let's say and I
mean like I'm I guess I'm kind of part
of it I'm an academic I write for the
New York Times people are laughing at
they were like oh what a funny guy you
know it's just a joke candidacy and I
sort of listened to him and I start
watching his social media and I started
going to his rallies to listen to him
and I thought wait
he's hitting a nerve he's reaching
people in ways that are ways in which
the established powers are blind to so
this is the thing like is the one you
asked me when did you first think it
of a danger it's also the first time I
thought this is great like I've been
feeling both feelings analytically
speaking together since it just came
through so you're talking about the loss
of control of old institutions and old
curators and I'm a part of the media
establishment so it's a it's a tragedy
tragedy basically no I'm just kidding
but I agree with you on that but there
seems to be something in this technology
that isn't just letting people you know
get the control absolutely there seems
to be something in this technology that
promotes certain types of content can
you talk a little bit how so in the old
establishment I'm kind of part of it
right now it was there was an ethos that
we failed from truth public service so
in the current environment you do not
have that ethos what you have is we talk
about the face right face
Google I think people shouldn't ignore
Google because YouTube let me give you
an example I think this example makes
kind of sense on YouTube which is owned
by Google which is owned by Google
because I was sitting Donald Trump I
started watching rallies of him on
YouTube because I wanted to also caught
from the rallies I was there I want to
quote from it so if you go to youtube
and watch a Donald Trump video a rally
you know if you ever go to YouTube
there's like this column on the right
that's sort of recommending things and
it autoplays them if you watch Donald
Trump YouTube starts recommending and
auto-playing white supremacist videos to
you and it just goes downhill very fast
like it starts with mild once it goes
downhill now you might be thinking oh
that's Donald Trump and that's just sort
of you know the right-wing in politics
if you go and watch Hillary Clinton or
Bernie Sanders which in the US are
Center center left it starts promoting
conspiracy left if you go to youtube and
watch a video about being vegetarian it
promotes being vegan like you start
getting videos about being vegan it's
like you never hardcore enough for
YouTube right it's just
really trying to push you to the edge if
you watch like normal stuff mainstream
stuff about say Islam as a religion you
will soon find yourself being Auto
played extremist terrorist ICC stuff
whatever you are YouTube is pushing you
to the edge why is YouTube doing this
YouTube's not doing this because it's
got a bunch of evil programmers what's
happening is that there's a new
technology and I'm a former programmer
right this is the technology side
there's a new technology called machine
learning which if you feed it enough
data it picks up on what people's
vulnerabilities are right and YouTube's
the machine learning algorithm which
nobody program Google just lets it loose
and says keep people on the site
whatever you do keep people on the site
that algorithm has figured out that
being seduced into the edge year side of
wherever you are if you listen to rock
it will give you heavy metal if you
listen to heavy metal it will give you a
trash metal if you listen to trash metal
it will give you death metal right it's
that annoying friend in college that's
always out doing you right what it's
figured out is that this is a human
vulnerability so he will keep you on
that thing it will play in play in play
while serving you ads and this is the
difference in the new reality Facebook
does a version of it the algorithms on
Facebook its user interface flattens
everything so that whether you're
watching and whether you're seeing
Denver Guardian a fake newspaper doesn't
exist I'm sorry that yeah they they made
up her name I think it was then
regarding or the New York Times it looks
the same and if it is something that's
gonna keep you on the side YouTube's out
if Facebook's algorithm will pick that
and show you and not the other stuff
because all it cares about his
engagement everything is flat everything
is content and the thing I like in this
too is that for very good reason humans
have weaknesses to sugar salt and fat
you evolve down there to Pleistocene
right I mean if you don't if your
ancestors didn't like sugar salt and fat
you probably wouldn't be here
being slightly more extreme stuff cuddly
stuff that's why your Facebook is full
of babies stuff that's outrageous stuff
that says things you already believe in
stuff that pushes you into things that
you already think are true that's the
sugar salt and fat of the information
ecology and we have two giant platforms
Facebook and Google whose whole program
is to give you sugar salt and fat for
breakfast lunch and dinner and then you
know without contact so I think that's
the big difference is that when
journalism failed and I criticize
journals and when it fails it failed at
least something to fail from whereas
when YouTube and Facebook succeed they
are giving you the kind of things that
aren't compatible in my view with a
healthy public sphere I think they're
not compatible with a world in which we
find a center a world in which we come
together I mean I I know I bashed
facebook all the time and this gets
worse for those machine learning
algorithms to work they need a lot of
data so they have to be the super
surveillance state they have to get
everything they have to collect as much
data they can about you so that they can
figure you out they can figure out your
vulnerabilities person by person by
person and it gets even worse I'm sorry
to be such a downer but I think we have
to confront this
it's screen by screen so you don't know
what your neighbors see so you cannot
have a world in which the good truth the
good speech can crowd out the bad speech
because it's directed at you and only
you
whatever your vulnerabilities are and
we're doing all of this just to serve
more ads it's like I might I'm just
gonna finish what I'm saying is this is
an infrastructure we're building that is
absolutely compatible with
authoritarianism
it's absolutely compatible with kinds of
power that I find scary because we won't
even see it it'll just happen and I
think we're just starting it and what's
worse for me and that will be my last
point and then I know I'm just going on
about this what force for me is that
Silicon Valley is
of very well-meaning people they're not
mean people they're not evil people they
set the structure up if it was just
bunch of evil people we would go get a
good mark zuckerberg we would get a good
you know sergey brin and we will solve
this problem we've set up an environment
in which we're promoting the worst
things about our public sphere and we're
already paying the price for it in lots
of countries so this is the way in which
I really worry that we're walking into
I've been calling a surveillance
authority and it's my really dangerous
historic moment and I hope we don't go
down this way yeah so I guess what
really is worrying about the case that
you are making is that we have this new
technology on one hand and on the other
hand is this economic incentives it's I
mean this basically comes down to the
advertising model it's correct it's
about keeping people on the platforms
for as long as possible to get their
data and so as you say there's no evil
scheme behind it it's just feeding into
the loop of correct
you know profit maximization and there's
nothing wrong with that but how do you
how should one think about this then as
a private citizen or even as someone
who's worrying about democracy what
should they do should we get off the
platform should we regulate what I don't
think we can get off the platforms I
mean to be honest I think at this point
Facebook and Google are quasi monopolies
I know you're obsessing about it at the
moment and I'm just talking about the
damage it's doing in countries like you
know you're in places like Europe like
in a lot of countries and countries like
the United States think of how much
displays out in for the next billion
Indonesia Philippines Myanmar Facebook
is the internet or Google that's it
and if I get out Facebook there are a
large number of people with some I would
not be able to stay in touch because
that's the only platform they use 90% of
every advertising dollar generated now
goes to Facebook or Google tell me about
it
there's a reason for it that's where
people are look there's a cafeteria that
is serving sugar salt and fat and
because of a bunch of reasons these
reasons are its Network effects if
people are there you're already gonna go
there look at what do we do then what do
we do it's a combination it's a
combination I think regulation of
certain kinds of things is important it
shouldn't be stupid regulation like some
of the things that are suggested aren't
workable we have to bring back
meaningful competition but if we just
break Facebook up and we have five eight
five Facebook's operating under the same
rules they'll just be five horrible
Facebook's instead of one big one that
sometimes try to do things right we'll
have five horrible ones that don't try
to do things right we have to change
their incentive structure as long as
their incentive structure is to keep you
on the side as long as possible to sell
your eyeballs to the advertisers we're
not gonna get rid of it I feel like the
business model has to be on the table
Facebook makes like $15 per person per
year we're ruining our public sphere for
$15 per person per year we should be the
customer of Facebook I would pay that
$15 and I would pay that $30 so that
somebody in the third world can have a
subsidized version of this like this it
is not that expensive I mean yes they're
making a lot of money because it's
because they got two billion people so
we pay for phones we pay for SIM cards
we pay for airtime why aren't we not the
product of what we can do you're talking
about going basically from an
advertising Manchester direction though
you need to be their loyalty and their
fealty has to be to us not to their
advertisers we have to limit how data
can be collected right now in the u.s.
at least Facebook can buy all the data
it wants in Europe it has some limits
that can't happen right now we've
empowered algorithms machine learning
algorithms do we go and say go ahead use
all the data and do what you want we
need to solve that and the problem is a
lot of times people just want
transparency over this because of the
way the technical way machine learning
work
transparency isn't gonna solve our
problem because you can look at all the
code you can look at all the data and
not you not the programmer not anyone
working on this any longer knows how it
works
google translate that magical thing that
translates between languages so well
it's 500 lines of code you will not be
able to tell anything if you look at the
code because machine learning works by
building what's called neural networks
so if you slice my brain you don't know
what I'm thinking right you just see
neurons if you look at these algorithms
you don't know what they're thinking so
we have to have ways of dealing with the
world in which we've turned over
decision-making to a kind of
intelligence machine intelligence that
we're no longer programming as much as
growing by feeding it data these are
huge challenges I feel like we can
address all of this but we have to do
this we have to bring more media
literacy and awareness into all of this
and finally I think we have to address
what are the fractures in which these
kinds of divisions are coming through
that the social media did well but we
have to adjust why is the sugar fat and
salt of the information sphere why is it
so attractive how can we dampen its
attractiveness how can we P give people
a healthier regime so that I think
there's like a million things we need to
do but we need to sort of just be very
realistic about what's going on and not
just think you know it's just a bunch of
evil people in Silicon Valley as I said
I wish that were the case but it would
be easier it would be easier I have one
last question for you because you have
been studying so the usage of social
medias you were talking about in the
introduction from people from dissenters
to authoritarian regimes and in your
latest book Twitter on teargas you
talked about how social media went from
being a tool of correct revolutionaries
to a weapon basically in the hand of
also return right how does that work can
you just talk about how they use it so
right now like from
we think a lot about free speech I think
about it's an important thing it's an
important American Valley we have the
First Amendment in the US it's amazing
but if you think about the point of free
speech is to have a marketplace of ideas
and to have a sane dialogue between
people whereas right now what is limited
is not speech its attention what's in
short supply and what is controlled by
Silicon Valley is attention and if you
think about how authoritarians think
it's not that they they used to keep
information from the people that is no
longer feasible but even if you can't
break the link between information to
people you can break the link between
information and action by polluting the
attention sphere with information glutes
you can just put so much information out
there people can't figure out what's
going on you can challenge the
credibility of information fake news
it's not true it's a hoax it's not this
like if you keep saying it and if you
keep pumping that kind of propaganda so
that there's so much noise that people
can't tell the signal that's the way of
censorship if you can distract people
China does this when there is something
going on here
China's has the so-called 50-cent army
which these are people employed by the
government researchers have found what
they do is they don't go engage the
political thing that's going on there
they go create a distraction there so
instead of censoring information by
manipulating attention by flooding the
information sphere with too much
information by challenge the credibility
of the actual entry actual information
by undermining institutions faulty or
not imperfect or not who are dedicated
to the unearthing of information and
truth right we talked about academia we
talked about journalism you know that
the previous panel talked about it by
undermining credibility and institutions
whose job it is to honor the information
the information will still be there for
someone like me there's
never been a better time to get at
information but for the public sphere
you can no longer figure out you know
where is the correct information to act
upon and I think this method is not just
something that works for authoritarians
in Russia in China it's increasingly
being used in our democracies to break
the link between information and healthy
action and that's the one that we have
to guard against not the blocking of
speech because we can get the speech out
how do we get the attention how do we
get the credibility those are my
questions so on that a bit note I'm a
cheery person and I think we can do this
I just feel like let's be realistic to
what we face thank you so much
[Applause]